MONDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED OF THE
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING IS
BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS AND IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE SERMONS WERE
MASK AT ALL TIMES. ATTENDEES
WAS OFFER FRIEND FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS TO SERVER
OTHEWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATION OF THESE RULES WERE
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO
REMOVAL ORDER FOR SOME PROCESS.
WHICH RESEARCHER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HERE CUNNINGHAM AND
I'VE- FOUR YEARS HERE WE ARE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS RUBIO.
WHO ARE HERE WEBER HERE WE HAVE
A QUORUM. FOR WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. MOVERS ARE
MAIENSCHEIN SECONDED BY MR LEE
OF MISTER TURPIS CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE LI LI I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS RAMOS
RUBIO. RUBIO RUBIO I VEHICULA
PEOPLE DRAW HOWEVER NEVER HIGH
MOTION PASSES. THE MOTION IS
PASSED FROM. FULL WHOLE THE
ROLE FOR HER FAMOUS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU MISTER. YEAH. STEP NUMBER
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN POINT WEBER
CONTENT ENACT CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BECAUSE CUNNINGHAM. THIS
RULE IS MEDIAN IS HEREBY
ADJOURNED.